it's great to welcome back to the
program today Brian class who is an
assistant professor of global politics
at University College London a columnist
for The Washington Post and also host of
the new podcast series power corrupts
Brian great to talk to you again thank
you so let's talk a little bit about the
Trump administration and geopolitics if
folks follow you on twitter they know
that you have no shortage of specific
and pointed critiques of how the current
president has been managing a variety of
different geopolitical relationships and
and and sort of day to day issues if you
were to sort of zoom out a little bit
how do you sum up the Trump
administration in terms of its
relationship to geopolitics and other
countries that's a great question so I
think there's there's two main things
that I would focus on the first one is
how Trump has changed our politics
towards authoritarian leaders and human
rights the second is how he's been a
Kaos agent with just about everything
else so to start the first one you know
there has not been really many dictators
of despots that Trump is not fawning
over right the one exception to this is
Nicolas Maduro in Venezuela but other
than that Trump has cozied up to every
single authoritarian leader he's
encountered writing me he said that he's
fallen in love with Kim jong-un he's
praised president Jeeves become
president for life effectively in China
he's praised President Erdogan who's
dismantled democracy in Turkey
he has praised president Duterte who's
committed thousands of extra butanol
killings and the Philippines you know he
has no shortage of love for you know el
Sisi in Egypt you name it
there is a trump tweet or some sort of
comment praising these dictators and
despots around the world and the point
that I'm trying to really make which i
think is underappreciated in u.s.
foreign policy circles is that everybody
outside of Egypt the Philippines Turkey
China what I would have you every every
other country in the world is paying
attention to this so when I've done
research in say Southeast Asia or
sub-saharan Africa they're taking cues
from what they can get away with from
what the US president says is except
and what might actually have
consequences and so my real worry is
that this rise of authoritarianism that
we've seen over the last 12 years where
the state of democracy has declined
globally every year for 12 years is
accelerating it's getting worse and that
we're gonna live in a much more
dangerous world more authoritarian it
can come so that's one big part of
trumps foreign policy that object to the
second and I'll be more concise with
this is the Kaos agent effectiveness
where Trump behaves in a way where he
doesn't really care about the
consequences he just does stuff and sees
what sticks right and and it has
consequences that are very predictable
so with the unilateral withdrawal from
the Iran agreement for example it is no
surprise that now there is a crisis and
international crisis that's spiraling
out of control around the Strait of
Hormuz in Iran it was predictable we
knew this was going to happen last last
year when you pulled out in the
agreement every export said this will
have a ratcheting effect an escalating
effect and now here it is right I mean
the trade war with China extremely
predictable consequences with
geopolitical risk baked in them and so
whatever issue he touches his very
cursory knowledge to put a charitably of
geopolitics and his sort of you know
offhand and tweets have real-world
consequences the problem I think is that
they take a while to manifest and so we
haven't seen the catastrophic risk that
he's creating come home to roost quite
yet but I suspect we will in the coming
year and that the destabilization is
going to get much much worse in 2020
well this relates to two topics I've
been talking about a lot one is the
shift of the Overton Window to the right
and the other is it not even to the
right it's more - it's really towards
authoritarianism actually as you're
pointing out and the creeping
normalization of how we expect a
president of the United States to behave
and act and the example I gave is if on
day one of the presidency Trump wanted
to debate caging immigrant children it
would have been too much too quickly and
so you really needed like the two and a
half years where you slowly slowly push
the conversation and then it's like well
do they deserve soap or don't day that
they deserve soap and that's why I feel
like you know think things move slowly
even in a four
year term the dynamics of the first half
of the term in the second half of the
term can be quite different and that's
the danger that I think causes a lot of
people not to realize how things have
shifted yeah I mean the analogy that
I've used in the past is that we're in
scandal overload right and that's that's
actually a huge gift to opening the
Overton Window because you can't really
keep track of all the scandals at once
you can't keep track of all the ways
you've busting norms and violating
American values because they're
happening so routinely and the analogy I
use we're like a golden retriever and
exploding tennis ball Factory right let
you catch one tennis ball in your mouth
for a minute and then another one comes
along and you chase that for a minute
and then another one comes along and in
the process you lose fact you lose sight
of the fact that the whole factory is
exploding right and so I think this is
this is exactly what's happened over the
last couple years is the unthinkable has
become routine and that as we continue
to accept new normals dangerous normals
as routine occurrences it gives the
encouragement to Trump to simply behave
that way because he gets away with it
right but I think this is something that
scares me about a second Trump term is
that it's the ultimate acceptance right
it's the ultimate sort of endorsement
that one has just happened for the
previous few years is acceptable we team
normal and we'll let it happen again
and if that happens if he gets another
term and he gets the endorsement of the
American public in even if it's a
contentious election he'll still take it
as a mandate I think the Overton Window
will expand much more in that second
term than in the first term that's why
I'm very very worried about what that
would look like for American democracy
foreign policy and the way our system of
government functions so to play devil's
advocate or really what I call stupid
devil's advocate because a lot of these
questions don't don't I think really
have to be considered as seriously as
maybe some would you've talked about a
lot of the ways in which other countries
are receiving signals from Trump about
what can they get away with and they are
sort of modifying their behavior as such
what about the argument that within the
United States there has not really been
any deleterious effect along these lines
as a result
of Trump cozying up to these
authoritarians worldwide and maybe in
fact it's gaining Trump I don't know to
play like really dumb devil's advocate
some kind of newfound respect from some
portions of the American electorate or
something right like fill it in with
whatever argument you want what about
the impact within the United States yeah
I mean so the thing is that when you
have foreign policy change over time you
know in places that most Americans don't
think about on a daily basis yeah the
average person doesn't feel that effect
right but the fact that the US for a
series of decades had cozied up to for
example dictators in North Africa and
the Middle East came home to roost when
the Arab Spring happened and if people
don't think that's affected them
I mean the amount of we had an
intervention in Libya we have the
destabilization of the Middle East
completely we had the refugee crisis
which has prompted a rise of far-right
politics in the UK in the UK and the EU
the US we have brexit partly fueled by
that collapse and the refugee problem
that it created and so you know all
these things take time to manifest but
when the world becomes more
authoritarian it becomes more dangerous
you know democracies are stable partners
they're stable allies that people you
can work with and trade with that don't
fundamentally collapse in the same way
that when the dictatorship Falls it
implodes a very dangerous wave that
destabilize the region all this stuff so
you know to me the aspects of endorsing
authoritarianism may not be felt in you
know July or August 2019 it's totally
possible and that's why Trump might get
away with it for quite a while longer
but the world has become going to become
much darker not just for the people who
are going to face much more egregious
human rights violations from autocrats
in power but also from the eventual fall
out when those regimes collapse as they
always do and it might happen as I say
in years it might happen in a decade but
you know like Trump's modus operandi
with business where he would stiff
people and stick them with the bill or
you know just simply not pay it he might
leave office with us to pay the bill of
his authoritarian style foreign policy
and I think that is going to be
something that will defy
American interests down the road even if
people say in the American heartland
don't realize it right now well that's
the exactly the next thing I wanted to
talk about which is early on in his
presidency there were a lot of sort of
slightly symbolic executive orders or
executive orders directing a department
to do a B or C but not really being a
significant change to policy then you
started getting into some directives
that did sort of connect to a policy
change but they could be pretty quickly
undone like as soon as the next
president is in who has a different idea
they can reverse some of those decisions
relatively quickly
is it the foreign policy geopolitical
stuff that is going to be of the most
lasting impact and most difficult to
quickly undo and I'm talking about
things like the tariff program with
China with no clear off ramp moving the
US Embassy in Israel to Jerusalem pick
whichever ones you want but are those
the most long-term to undo areas of the
presidency yes I think I think yes or no
I mean on the foreign policy aspects of
this what Trump is sending in motion is
difficult to undo because long-term
strategic orientation stuff right the
trade war with China
you can't just undo that on day one even
if you get rid of the tariffs China is
going to think about the u.s.
differently you know US trade policy
will be fundamentally transformed I
think the thing that's really going to
be difficult to undo for a Democratic
president saying that if they win in
2020 is the credibility aspect right
because you have polls in places like
Germany a historic US ally where the
German public nouns used the US and
Russia as equal threats right I mean
that's just unbelievable and eventually
that is going to shift German politics
to actually make strategic changes to
how they think about the United States
the same is happening here in the UK
where people are thinking less about the
United States as a benevolent Ally and
more as something you're the hedge your
bets against because they're not
reliable they can't be trusted etc and
so I think that is going to be very very
difficult to change but I do think the
domestic stuff is gonna be really
difficult to reverse course on for
particularly something you talked about
before the Overton Window
decline of norms in u.s. politics I mean
once the genie is out of the bottle of
how the president behaves by bashing the
press scapegoating minorities telling
constant lies violating ethics rules you
know hiring cronies and family members
into higher office how do you just go
back to the old system I mean I think
there is a series of a huge percentage
of the electorate you know whether it's
thirty five or forty five percent of the
electorate isn't just okay with this
stuff they cheer for it they want it and
so my worry is that you're going to have
the loss of confidence in the United
States from people abroad particularly
our allies at the same time that the
Republican Party may be permanently
transformed into one that uses trumpism
as its rallying cry and that is a very
difficult problem to undo even if you
have a well-intentioned Republican
candidate in 2020 or god help us 2024
I'm sorry I'm sorry the Republican
candidate comes out in 2024 after Trump
loses hopefully yeah that would be
something where the damage is going to
take I think much more than one election
cycle to repair probably more like
decades and I know that's depressing to
hear but I think I think it's also true
and it's certainly something that I'm
hearing on this side of the Atlantic by
people who think about the United States
very differently from the Obama years
yeah I mean not that this is in any way
analogous but in I was born in Argentina
and after many years of one of the most
corrupt presidents in a very long time
cristina kirchner a president who is
like a center-right guy makhani was able
to win even with support from people who
would not typically vote for a center
rightist because of the sort of
positioning as I'm going to stop the
corruption I'm going to stop the
cronyism I just don't know that that
sort of anti-corruption backlash is as
likely to take hold in the United States
given the sort of partisan environment
in which it would have to would have to
operate yeah I mean this is this is the
real kryptonite of American democracy is
hyper polarization because it destroys
accountability and so things that
normally would command you know
bipartisan support
or would immediately be rejected by
massive bipartisan majorities are now
splitting along partisan lines right I
mean you have one of the examples of
this that I thought was particularly
horrifying was it's now a largely
forgotten because of that scandal
overload I talked about before the Trump
stood on the stage with Greg Jian for
the Republican congressman from Montana
yeah last year before the election and
endorsed him not in spite of the fact
but because of the fact that he
violently assaulted or cornered him he
was literally arrested and convicted of
physical assault of a journalist and
Trump didn't just endorse him but then
playfully mocks the body-slamming he did
at the journalist which broke his
glasses it was such force and it's like
old news now right so the idea that that
would only split along partisan lines
doesn't bode well for all the other
aspects of reform that happened for
example after the Watergate scandal
there was bipartisan support for reform
of government and it actually ushered in
a lot of clean government initiatives
that were useful in rebuilding trust in
American democracy in American
government and I'm worried that that
won't happen after the Trump years
because Republicans who have drank the
kool-aid of trumpism are just going to
say we actually liked it we don't think
he was corrupt we don't think that I
mean this behavior was unacceptable
therefore we're going to block in the
initiatives and try to make sure that it
doesn't happen again and so that's where
you know my pessimistic streak really
kicks in is what I think you know are we
really going to come to our senses I'd
like to believe that there's gonna be
this moment where a light bulb goes off
and people say oh no you know we were
blind to these abuses but with hyper
partisanship and hyperpolarization it
may not happen it may not and we will
certainly have a lot to contend with if
that's the case we've been speaking with
Brian clasp who's an assistant professor
of global politics at University College
London
check out the new podcast series which
he hosts power corrupts Brian always so
great to talk to you
thanks so much Fred of me on as a
pleasure